Alright guys, so this is a brand new course and every week there will be a new chapter
that's going to be released in the Discord server.
And in this very first chapter, I'm going to teach you guys about the Monday range.
It is a very good model with high win rate.
It works on Gold, NAS100, EuroUSD, GBP, USD, okay.
So essentially what we're doing is we are marking out high of the Monday and low of
the Monday.
So let's assume that this candle on the daily time from is the Monday candle and it closes.
So we mark out the Monday high and the Monday range low, okay.
Now on Tuesday, we want to see price take out either the swing, sorry, the Monday high
or the Monday low, okay.
So let's assume that on Tuesday, the low is taken out.
The low of the Monday is taken out.
What we want to do is we want to simply drop down to 15 minute time frame.
So we'll drop down to 15 minute time frame.
And then we're going to look for a market structure shift, right.
And we're going to take our entry and we can target the Monday high or we can take our
profit at the 50% of this Monday range, right.
So we can take our profit somewhere around here or we can simply go for one to two.
Now key thing to note is that you should get your market structure shift during London
session because let's assume that you get your market structure shift during Asian session.
Now this will then become the Asian session low.
So there's a chance that price will take out the Asian low first and then give you another
market structure shift and move towards the Monday high, okay.
So remember this one thing.
We are looking for market structure shift during London or New York session.
If the market structure shift occurs during the Asian session, right, then we have to
keep the Asian range strategy in the first course in our mind.
And we have to think about it logically, right.
As if we get the market structure shift during the Asian session, we can expect the price
to take out the Asian low first and then move towards the Monday high.
So similarly, if the Monday candle high is taken out first, we're going to drop down
to the 15 minute time frame, right.
And then we're going to look for a market structure shift and then we're going to look
to take our entry from the Fair Valley gap or an auto block and we're going to target
the Monday low.
Very simple, okay.
So to increase the probabilities, we can do is look for SMT divergence.
It is not necessary, but what it's going to do is it's going to confirm, you know, the
momentum, but it's not necessary and it requires, this model requires no delay bias and this
is like a one trade per week setup and it has a very high event rate.
So if you are someone who has, you know, a 95 job or you just busy with your family
or whatnot, right, you can just take one set of per day and make a living.
So I'm going to give you guys some examples and then I'll be back next week with a new
chapter.
Okay, guys.
So here is example number one and you can see this is the Monday candle and that close.
So all you have to do is mark out the Monday candle high and the Monday candle low.
You can see that on Tuesday, the low of the Monday candle was taken out.
So if I drop down to 15 minute time frame, right, this is the Monday low, right, and it
was taken out first and we have our Monday high over here.
So you can simply see that what happened.
We got a market structure shift, right, of during the kills and ours and then you can
see that we had this breaker block and afterwards price tapped into this and it just flew away.
Now of course, this is hindsight, primarily you want to be taking, trying to take your
entry from the auto block, right?
But since the range was so big, you want to get into the trade as soon as possible.
So for example, even if I took my trade here, right, I put my stop somewhere around here.
This would have easily given me around 3.5 one, okay?
The general rule of thumb, a very good rule of thumb is that you always go for one to
two risk to reward, right?
And all of us go break even after one to one is hit.
So that was a very clean example.
Let's move on to another example now.
Okay guys, so in this example, you can see that I've marked out the Monday candle high
and the Monday candle low.
So you can clearly see how well this played out.
So I'm going to drop down to 15 minute time from here and if I zoom out a bit, you can
see that the Monday low was here and it was taken out on Tuesday.
And simply what we would do is we would look for a market structure shift and that happened
just around here.
Now if you see this, that we were outside decals and ours.
Now you could have taken your entry from this break of block here, right?
But eventually what I would do is I would wait for the next day and the next London
session to start and then I would look for a liquidity purge.
So continuation purge in the first course, right afterwards we have a break in the structure
then we have the auto block here and you can see the beautiful delivery to the upside,
taking out the Monday candle high.
Let's move on to another example.
All right guys, so here is another example.
This is going to be a different example because I'm going to show you a loser and I'm going
to also show you that as long as you have, you know, your idea, right, you can still
get re-enter into the trade.
So over here you can see we have the Monday high and the Monday low, right?
So if I go to the 15 minute time frame, you're going to see that the Monday high was taken
out first.
So what we were doing is looking for a market structure shift.
So over here, what we had, we had the Asian session high taken out and somewhere around
here, we had a market structure shift and now we did push up, we did mitigate this auto
block and then we did go below it, but price had another push up, right?
And then afterwards, we had a shift in the market structure over here, right?
And over here.
So then we had this auto block here and you can see the beautiful tap and you can see
how price delivered by taking out the Monday low.
All right guys, so here is another example.
This time looking at gold.
So you can see on Monday, we have a Monday high and the Monday low.
So now you can see that price first took out the Monday low and then went up ahead and took
out the Monday high.
So if I go to the 15 minute time from here, you're going to see that on Tuesday, we had
a purge on the Monday low, right?
And that's what we want to see afterwards.
What do we have is a, if you see, look closely, this is a high, right?
So this was broken.
And then what we are simply doing is taking our entry from the breaker block or a fair
valley gap.
So you can see that we have this fair valley gap and the entry was perfect right here.
And you can see that the draw on liquidity was taken out.
So you can see that we had a push up.
You could have gone break even at somewhere around here, right?
After these highs were taken out or at one to one and this would have a break down perfectly.
So let me go because one more example.
All right.
Guess.
So here's the last example.
You can see that we have a Monday candle, the Monday high and the Monday low.
So you can see that the Monday high was taken out first.
So if I go to the 15 minute time from here, you can see that I have marked out the Monday
high over here.
And on Tuesday, the Monday high was taken out.
So now we're looking for a market structure shift.
The market structure shift happened just around here.
And then what we have is a consecutive bullish candles to the upside.
This could be your entry level, right?
So a short position just right here, stop right above here.
And you can see that the take profit was easily hit.
So that is it for this chapter guys.
I really hope that this works out for you.
There are a lot of more models coming up.
I can't wait to show you guys, but I'm going to keep it slow.
One model per week because I want you to get familiar with every single model and I want
you to practice every model because at the end of this brand new course, you're going
to thank me.
Okay.
So just keep watching, keep back practicing and keep back testing.